Er-neener-neener-neener-neener-nee~
Wave hi to the camera!
Good morning, John, it's Wednesday, February
eleventh,
and I'm almost entirely sure that I actually got the
date right this time!
It's Wednesday!
[Singing] Song Wednesday!
This song is a little bit different than usual,
because instead of recording with me and my acoustic guitar,
and then later going to the studio to record it for my album,
I just recorded it at the studio to start with,
so you're getting the studio version,
first-ever viewing,
here, on Brotherhood 2.0!
I'm not really sure what to call this song.
I've got a few ideas, but I was wondering
if you guys had ideas, as well,
so if you could leave those in the comments,
the best one I will choose, and then I'll
link to your channel in the sidebar, which
is actually over there [not anymore].
Without further ado, here's my song about
an anglerfish!
[Upbeat music]
[Song ends]
I hope that you enjoyed that!
Please don't forget to leave potential song
titles in the comments; I need to get a title
of the song!
And, secondarily, DFTBA Records is having the DFTBA Radio Hour tonight,
in which Toddly00 and Caitlin Sky will be talking about
all things nerdy, all things DFTBA, all things musical, and all things awesome.
9:00 PM, Eastern Standard Time!
There's a link in the sidebar.
John, I hope you enjoyed my music!
I enjoyed your Question Tuesday, and I especially enjoyed Captain Willie's Voyage of a Failboat.
Don't forget to be awesome.